(upbeat reggae music)
- [Voiceover] Once upon a
time there was a temple,
it was pretty dope.
Three goddesses lived there.
The Truth Goddess, who
always told the truth.
The Lie Goddess, who lied down a lot,
but also was a huge liar.
And the Wisdom Goddess,
who sometimes lied,
and sometimes told the truth.
Weirdly, all three
looked exactly the same,
so no body could tell them apart.
One day a traveler came
by, and he was like,
"Yo, I got a dentist
appointment, can you guys move?"
The Goddesses said, "You may only pass if
"you tell us apart, so
give it a shot I guess."
He asked the Goddess on the left,
"Who's the middle Goddess?"
"Truth," she replied.
He asked the Goddess in
the middle, "Who are you?"
"Wisdom," she answered.
He asked the Goddess on the right,
"Who is the middle Goddess?"
"She's the liar," the Goddess replied.
The man made his dentist
appointment, and boy,
did his teeth sparkle.
How did he tell the Goddesses apart?
- I have no idea, I'm
already, this is terrible.
- Is there like a phone-a-friend option?
- I feel like the middle
Goddess would say.
- See that's the other
thing, I don't really
give up too easily.
- If you asked Goddess
that lies, if you go,
"Hey what color's my shirt?"
You're wearing a white
shirt, and the Goddess says,
"You're wearing a black shirt."
You know she's lying.
- Wisdom sometimes says what?
A little of each?
A little of each.
That's not very helpful.
If she is Truth, then she can't be
saying that the other girl's Truth.
- That could still make that one Truth,
still telling the truth,
no, no, no, no, no.
- And then you'll figure out
that's the Truth Goddess,
and then to the left,
is the lying Goddess.
- Also, just to let you
know, I'm real tired.
- Liar, middle wisdom,
right true, wisdom, truth.
- Last I think I said was,
wisdom, middle was lying
and right was true.
- Is that true?
Is this it, is that the answer? (chuckles)
- Yeah, go ahead, just tell it to me.
- [Voiceover] The left Goddess is Wisdom,
the middle Goddess is lying,
and the right Goddess is Truth.
The Goddess on the left
said the middle on is Truth.
So, the left cannot be
Truth because they're cannot
be two Truth Goddesses.
The Goddess in the middle
said she was Wisdom.
In that case, she cannot be Truth,
or she would have said so.
So, the Goddess on the
right must be Truth,
and according to her,
the middle one is Lie.
As a result, the Goddess
on the left is Wisdom.
(upbeat reggae music)